welcome back uh with my Pat Paula and
Madeline also delighted to be joined I
say delighted I've just found something
else which may make that look ridiculous
but let me joined by a very famous
comedian he's an Egyptian uh comedian
called basa Musa who somehow has 10.9
million toilet followers which is more
than me it's currently on tour in the UK
with a new show it's amazing I was about
to congratulate you on having more
followers of me and I went to look at
you on Twitter and discovered I blocked
you yes you blocked I bumped you to
discuss cancel
me why did I block you uh well I was
mean to you what did you say uh well you
see I'm already I I admitted that was me
yeah it was there during the 6th of
January uh resurrection and you were of
course angry and then I was angry and
then I said like said the guy who had
Donald Trump with him on his profile
picture ah and then of course you
blocked me yeah well okay I've unblocked
you yeah I've now followed you if you're
uncancel although I don't think being
blocked on Twitter is canceling no it's
not it's not because you're still able
to do what you want to do free you're
free you shouldn't be forced to listen
no right no democracy isn't is a noisy
Place yeah but I don't have to be there
when I don't listen to something do you
two block people not much actually I
prefer
this is Chris Rock so we're we're only a
few days away from the Oscars and it was
a year ago that the slap that went
around the world was see where Chris
Rock was punched by Will Smith for
apparently mocking uh Will Smith's wife
Jada this is what Christoph Roth Chris
Rock said in his Netflix special this
week about this
that's right you said it
Rubble say they always say uh words hurt
that's what they say gotta watch what
you say cause words hurt
you know anybody that says words hurt
has never been punched in the face
okay Sebastian look you're a comedian
highly successful but you come from
Egypt where you know a lot of censorship
goes on but a suppression goes on uh not
unknown I suspect for comedians to get
you know punished or even put in prison
on occasion well I got my hair my show
canceled a couple of times right and I
had to venture to leave so that that's
for me is cancer but you fled to the
west where you hoped there would be
Liberation and freedom for people like
you and you've come to a place where
comedians are now getting punched and
assaulted not just Chris Rock I think uh
Dave chappella happened to on stage and
others uh often for expressing in
Chappelle's case you know a view about
say the transgender debate which seemed
to be completely reasonable
what does that say about comedy and
where we are and how does comedy come
through this attempt to basically
physically beat it into submission well
first of all people a lot people say can
comedy survive cancer culture my
question is can cancer cultures survive
comedy because comedy will always be
there you cannot cancel comedy you could
be outraged you can punch you can slap
but these are isolated cases if you have
someone sort of attack you uh no no what
would you do if they did would you I
would punch you back because I work out
in the gym
Chris Rock of punch Will Smith back no I
think Chris Rock got his revenge a year
later with a 40 million dollar check
from Netflix yes so that is something
that will last longer uh I would have
loved if Chris Rock had sued
Will Smith because that was not cancer
culture but this is assault no but it's
interesting isn't it because I remember
at the time writing a piece almost
defending Will Smith to a bit where I
thought if he genuinely believed Chris
Rock who had history of doing this to
Jada Pinkett Smith Will's wife of
mocking her if he genuinely thought that
Chris Rock at the Oscars in front of a
billion viewers was mocking his wife's
alopecia because she'd lost her hair I
think a lot of men might have stepped in
and given him a slap so it may have
seemed insane but it didn't seem that
insane to me of a husband defending his
wife against what he may have thought
was a very personal attack I don't know
I mean it's the Oscars isn't it it's not
the WWE you can't decide in principal
people you can't go punching people
because I'm not saying is right I'm
saying I could understand he's got two
kids he's got to set an example to his
kids yeah I'm watching Yellowstone at
the moment the cowboy drama with Kevin
Costner every time there's anything any
argument they punch each other so I mean
there's something quite you know it's a
throwback but I'm not against it if
people buy it badly and as a martial
artist I can understand the need you're
martial artist I am a martial wow I can
understand the need to want to defend
yourself but I think Madeleine is right
you defend yourself in a smart way and
Chris Rock has been Smart in that he's
now got that paycheck but if you allow
people to have a leeway of using
physical Force to stop people where do
you draw the line I agree I think I
think it's when you cross the lines when
performers are performing if you try and
do that it's completely wrong massive
where are we with the woke culture in
comedy because Bill Maher in America
says they've become now a much better
source of joke material than the than
the far right well you know with the
pendulum the pendulum Theory it goes so
far to the right it comes back too far
to the rest now a lot of people make fun
of the War culture and I think if people
please yeah sometimes but I I my comedy
is more about my personal Journey but I
do sometimes in comedy because if when a
group of people feel themselves too
entitled
too isolated too protected that's what
happens this is what happened with Dave
Chappelle I mean like uh why would
transgender people all Muslim people or
gay people or women be immune to satire
well this is a comedian Echo burn a
manner it was a rough Northern comic
very inappropriate about today's status
very offensive but his view was he used
to mock everybody because he couldn't
understand why if you started making
exceptions well where do you stop yeah
there is a kind of Purity to that
argument absolutely because a lot of
people say where do you draw the line
the better question is who will draw the
life yeah and how do you guarantee that
tomorrow that line will not proceed on
your own freedoms well I'm going to draw
the line here bass if you're on tour at
the moment good luck with the tour I'm
so glad I've unblocked you oh thank you
I'm happy that I came here follow me and
tell your followers to follow me and be
I'd be nice and be nicer thank you both
very much indeed uh well that's it from
me